Der Urquell aller technischen Errungenschakten ist die göttliche Neugier und der Spieltrieb des bastenden und grübelnden Forschers und nicht minder die konstruktive Fantasie des technischen Erfinders.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 19 und heute gibt's mal wieder ein bisschen Feedback um die Uhren und ein interessantes Interview, was ich geführt habe zum Thema Fon. Am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove. Das ist ein DJ-Mix diesmal vom Macher des Zerinnerungsnetlabels und das ist das Set so wie es auf der letzten Netlabel-Party lief, die ganz nett war. Ja, Chaosradio Express. Diesmal relativ schnell wieder eine neue Ausgabe. Das hat sich zufällig ergeben, weil ein interessanter Gast in der Stadt war und den habe ich dann mal interviewt. Bevor ich aber zu dem Thema komme, wollte ich zunächst einmal noch ein bisschen Feedback einspielen, was eingekommen ist, hereingekommen ist, beziehungsweise auch per E-Mail bei uns aufgelaufen ist. Zunächst einmal der Hinweis zu der GPL-Sendung. Raphael hat uns eine Mail geschickt und uns darauf hingewiesen, dass es sehr wohl eine deutsche Übersetzung gibt, wenngleich auch keine offizielle. Bei O'Reilly erschienen, wo soll es auch anders sein? Die GPL kommentiert und erklärt gibt es unter oreilly.de Katalog slash GPLGER. Den Link findet ihr natürlich auch auf der Webseite zum Chaosradio Express Podcast und dort gibt es auch gerade die Übersetzung als PDF Download, also das Kapitel, wo die GPL übersetzt ist, gibt es einfach als PDF zum freien Download und in dem Buch steht dann sicherlich noch sehr viel mehr Interessantes zur GPL. Ich habe es selber nicht gelesen. Der zweite Kommentar zur vorhergegangenen Sendung hat uns dann über das Feedback-Telefon erreicht. Da hören wir doch gleich mal live rein.
Ja, hallo, hier ist der Evil aus dem schönen Thüringen. Ich hab eine Frage und zwar zum letzten Chaosradio Express und zwar zum Thema Dropping Knowledge. Ich meine, das ist ja alles schön und gut, dass die Leute da jetzt von allen möglichen Bevölkerungsschichten Fragen sammeln und die dann irgendwelchen Wissenschaftler oder sonstigen stellen, aber welchen sinnvollen Hintergrund hat das Ganze? Was bezwecken die damit? Wird in unserer Welt dadurch schöner, besser, toller? Oder was machen die bitte ganz genau mit diesen Fragen? Und warum stellen die das diesen Fragen? Was versprechen die sich davon? Vielleicht könnt ihr dazu einfach noch mal eine Antwort geben. Ich danke euch.
Ja, sinnvoller Hintergrund. Also den sinnvollen Hintergrund vermag ich gar nicht zu bewerten. Da muss man die Leute einfach schon mal selber fragen, inwieweit die Welt da jetzt besser wird. Ja, keine Ahnung, ob wir überhaupt die Richtigen sind, das zu bewerten. Ich denke, damit muss man auch erst mal abwarten und die Leute einfach nach ihren Taten bewerten. Also ich kann schwer sagen, welche Fragen und welche Antworten hier die Welt bewegen, wenn man diese Fragen noch gar nicht kennt, geschweige denn die Antworten. Letztlich ist das Projekt zumindest schon mal produktiv. Da kommen Filme bei raus, da kommen Dokumentationen bei raus. Ich denke, das werden wir alles sehen. Grundsätzlich verspüre ich aber hier schon mal so einen sanften Wertewandel in der Gesellschaft. Wir haben einen Innenminister, der jede Woche um Woche neue Forderungen aufstellt, die dann regelmäßig vom Verfassungsgericht wieder verworfen werden. Und ein Parlament, was ohne groß nachzudenken eine Freiheitseinschränkung nach der anderen durchwinkt. Und ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht wird es langsam mal wieder Zeit für eine außerparlamentarische Opposition. Der hat sich ja auch während einer großen Koalition gebildet. Immerhin muss man jetzt nicht vor dem Axel Springer-Verlag protestieren. Jetzt gibt es einen Bildblock, jetzt gibt es überhaupt ein Internet. Es gibt Blogs, es gibt Podcasts und es gibt viele andere Medien, die man jetzt nutzen kann, eine Öffentlichkeit, die es so damals nicht gab. Insofern ist es auch irgendwie an uns, Alternativen zu formulieren, denke ich. Einfach mal ein eigenes Modell entwickeln, sich immer nur beklagen, so das eine, mal alles scheiße finden und gut, die marschieren auf ihre Art und Weise voran, andere marschieren auf ihre Art voran und grundsätzlich kann ich Aktivität eigentlich nur gut heißen, inwiefern der Hintergrund sinnvoll ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, wir werden das alles am Ergebnis messen. Mehr können wir da eigentlich auch nicht zu sagen. Ja, zweiter Einwurf per Telefon kommt von Jan. Hören wir mal rein, hier geht es jetzt um die Sendung zum Mesh Networking.
Ja, hallo, das spricht der Jan. Ich hab mir eben das Mesh Networking angehört, diesen Podcast. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, von wann das ist, aber 2.06. Und welches Thema ich vermisst habe, so ein System ist natürlich die Sicherheit, die Daten wandern ja von den einem Point zu dem anderen. Und da wurde halt nichts über die Sicherheit, Verschleunigung oder sonst was gesagt. Man kann das sicherlich irgendwo nachlesen, aber halt schon nur so als Feedback wäre auch vielleicht ein kurzer interessantes Kapitel in diesem Wort.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall interessantes Kapitel. Ich glaube, zur Sicherheit haben wir uns so explizit nicht geäußert. Es ist natürlich auch ein weites Feld, immer die Frage Sicherheit von was. OLSR ist im Wesentlichen ein System, um das Weiterleiten der Pakete zwischen diesen dynamisch sich selbst entdeckenden Netzknoten zu regeln. Und die Daten werden zwischen diesen Knoten genauso weiter gereicht, wie das eben bei allen anderen Internet-Hosts auch ist. Also es ist ein Mesh-Network, unterscheidet sich eigentlich von einem anderen IP-Netzwerk nur dadurch, dass die Wegfindung durch dieses Netz eben sehr dynamisch stattfindet, dass diese Routen sich immer wieder neu finden. Während es halt beim Internet-Service-Provider, die tauschen halt da ihre Routing-Tabellen aus und auf der Basis werden die Daten halt weitergeleitet. Aber dadurch werden die Daten selber nicht modifizieren. Also in dem Moment, wo ihr ein OLSR-Netz nutzt, ist es eigentlich, zumindest was die Sicherheit betrifft, kein anderes Thema. Und da ist die Antwort halt immer dieselbe, wenn ihr die Daten nicht verschlüsselt, dann sind sie halt nicht verschlüsselt. Und von daher ist man da auch jetzt nicht sicherer oder weniger sicher als überall sonst auch. Nur weil man vielleicht direkt an seinem DSL-Anschluss die Daten verschickt und das jetzt so zunächst erstmal keine Privatperson dazwischenhängt, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass das irgendwo auf dem langen Weg zu dem Server, mit dem du dich in dem Moment gerade verbinden willst, Web-Server, E-Mail, Login, was auch immer, heißt ja nicht, dass da nicht auch irgendwo jemand dazwischen ist. Kann auch beim Internet-Service-Provider sein. Das sind auch nur gelangweilte Angestellte, die irgendwie nichts zu tun haben. Ich will es den Internet-Service, die Mitarbeiter der Internet-Service-Provider jetzt nicht unrecht tun, aber ihr wisst schon, was ich meine. Also Vertrauen ist gut, Kontrolle ist besser und Verschlüsselung ist eigentlich das Beste. Von daher achtet da drauf, wenn ihr E-Mail verwendet, macht es nicht über ungesicherte Protokolle, benutzt nicht POP ohne SSL, benutzt auch am besten nicht SMTP ohne SSL, benutzt eigentlich möglichst gar nichts, ohne eine explizite Verschlüsselung. Auch bei der Benutzung normaler Websites sollte man immer wieder darüber nachdenken, ob es nicht vielleicht die Alternative gibt, das eine oder andere auch über HTTPS zu sichern. Wenn ihr euren eigenen Server aufsetzt zum Beispiel, wo ihr euch einloggt, überall wo man sich eben einloggt, und es handelt sich einfach nur um HTTP, also zumindest wenn man das Passwort, also in dem ersten Moment, wo man das eingebt, dann kommen ja häufig auch noch diese Cookies dazu, die gesetzt werden, das ist alles nur vorgetäuschte Sicherheit. In dem Moment, wo die eigentliche Verbindung zwischen eurem Computer und dem Gegenüber nicht verschlüsselt ist, ist es halt einfach mal unsicher. So einfach kann man das festhalten. Und OLSR ändert da auch nichts. OLSR ist trotzdem ein schönes Protokoll und hat gezeigt, wie man alternative Netze aufbauen kann in Bereichen, wo es keine Infrastruktur gibt. Und das leitet auch schon über zu dem Hauptthema dieser Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express. Es gibt ein neues Projekt, bekannt geworden unter dem Namen Fon. Fon will ein übergreifendes weltweites System zur gemeinsamen Nutzung von Internetzugängen sein. Hierbei geht es vor allem um den Zugang über Wireless-LAN. Das heißt, Leute werden hier aufgefordert, ihre heimischen Internetzugänge über WLAN dritten zugänglich zu machen. Manche von euch werden das vielleicht auch schon mal getan haben. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch ganz einfach. Man braucht nur seinen WLAN-Router so zu konfigurieren, dass er kein Passwort hat und dann kann natürlich jeder rein. Da hat man natürlich auch noch ein anderes Problem, weil dann kann halt auch wirklich jeder rein. Und dann nutzen vielleicht auch einige Leute die eigenen Leitungen auf eine Art und Weise, wie einem das nicht recht ist. Sei es jetzt, indem sie irgendwelche Verstöße gegen irgendwelche Gesetze begehen oder auch nur einfach die Bandbreite in einem Maße regeln, wie es einem grad nicht passt. Man hat in der Regel relativ wenig Einflussmöglichkeiten bei dem eigenen WLAN-Router, das so einzustellen, wie man das gerne haben möchte, wenn man halt grundsätzlich bereit ist, seine Internetleitung mit anderen zu teilen. Fon versucht jetzt, ein übergreifendes Login-System bereitzustellen und das Ganze geht einher mit einer neuen Software für den WLAN-Router. Das ist derzeit noch beschränkt auf bestimmte Geräte, vornehmlich nämlich diese Linksys-Geräte, die auch bei OLSR schon das Thema waren. Das überrascht halt nicht, weil das Gerät eben unter Linux lief, bzw. es auch immer noch eine Linux-Variante gibt. Es gibt auch mittlerweile eine Nicht-Linux-Variante. Wer dazu mehr empfaden will, kann auch mal Chaosradio Express 16 nachschlagen. Und Fon stellt nun eine komplett neue Firmware für WLAN-Rotor bereit, die auf einer Open-Source-Lösung bzw. auf zwei Open-Source-Lösungen basieren, DD-WRT und Open-WRT, und bietet für alle Leute, die sich dort eben registrieren, einen Single-Login und dann kann man eben jedes WLAN, was irgendjemand mit einem Router, was diese Firmware für den WLAN-Router hat, kann das jeder eben benutzen. Man hat also quasi nur ein Login und kann sich an jedem Fon-Router einloggen und hat Internet. Man kann da auch Geld mit verdienen, wenn das gewünscht ist. Man kann es aber auch frei machen. Bekannt geworden ist das vor allem, weil Google und Skype jetzt in den letzten Wochen bekannt gegeben haben, dass sie da 20 Millionen in dieses Projekt reinschütten. Das hat eine ganze Menge Leute die Ohren geöffnet, unter anderem auch mir. Es gab jetzt die Gelegenheit für mich heute ein Interview zu führen mit Martin Varsavsky, der Projektleiter von Fon ist, der zufällig in Berlin war. Ich habe mich eine halbe Stunde mit ihm unterhalten. Das ist ein Interview auf Englisch, aber ich denke es ist gut verständlich. Dieses Interview deckt eine ganze Menge Details auf, wie Fon sich das vorstellt, welche Ziele sie haben, wie ihr Bezahlsystem funktioniert, ihr Verhältnis zur Open Source-Gemeinde, und noch einige andere interessante Aspekte. Ich spiele das jetzt mal ein und wünsche euch viel Spaß bei dem Interview. Okay, ich sitze hier mit Martin Varsavsky. Er ist der Founder von drei ISPs, so weit ich weiß, und auch der Founder von Fon, was eine neue Firma ist, die gerade auf dem Markt geht. Ist das eine realistische Beziehung?
Ich hatte das Idee von Fon im September, und wir haben im November die Software ausgel. Wir hatten 3.000 Foneros am Anfang dieses Monats. Dann haben wir mit Google und Skype beigetragen, die unsere Partner geworden sind. Wir sind in rund 20.000 Blogs im Weltmeer und 220 Nachrichten und das war natürlich ein enormer Weg, die Phone-Story zu erzählen. Wir hatten noch 3.000 Foneros erwartet, also 6.000 und das größte Hot-Spot-Netzwerk im Weltmeer hat 25.000 Hot-Spots. Aber es ist unglaublich, es ist phänomenal. Und jetzt habe ich keine Ahnung, ob wir das größte Hotspot-Netzwerk im Welt werden, und bevor Dezember.
Waren wir über Leute, die bereits eine WiFi-Konnection schenken, oder nur Leute, die auf die Netzwerke eingeführt haben?
Wenn sie bereits die Linksys-Router haben, die wir benutzen, dann downloaden sie die Software in ihren Laptops oder desktops, verbinden ihre Routers und verändern die Firmware. Dann werden sie Phoneros. Wenn nicht, werden wir die Linksys-Router anbieten. Dann gehen Sie an fond.com, kaufen den Router und spielen. Die Welt, die von Phon her kommt, ist eine Welt, in der es drei Typen der Welt gibt. Das ist die Mehrheit der Menschen im Welt. Die Bauern kommen in zwei Typen. Die Linus und die Builds. Obwohl Linus von Linus Torval und Builds von Bill Gates. Wir von Phon denken, dass Bill Gates ein Hero ist und dass Linus Torval ein Hero ist.
Was ist das, um ein Phon Linus zu werden, um mein eigenes Netzwerk zu öffnen?
Wir lieben das, wenn Leute WiFi schenken, wie sie es können. Wir sind hier in den Orten von Places. Places zeigen in ihren Maps, wo wir sind. Es ist eine Gemeinschaft von Leuten, die WiFi schenken. Aber wenn du einfach WiFi schenken willst und nicht Teil einer Gemeinschaft bist, dann ist das auch gut. Aber wir denken, Phon bietet auch eine sichere Art, WiFi zu schenken. Und wir denken auch, dass es viele andere Incentive gibt. Und es gibt auch einen sozialen Element zum Phon. Es gibt also einen ganzen sozialen Blogging-Element zum Phon. Und letztlich werden die Phon-Hotspots bald gemischt. Die IP-Tables werden die Kommunikation mit deinen Nachbarn über WiFi und nicht über Internet verbreiten. Du kannst also eine private Kommunikation mit deinen Nachbarn haben, die nicht über Internet geht.
Wir reden hier über Mesh-Netzwerken, über OLSR-Netzwerken, oder was für eine Technologie ist die Basis deines Mesh-Netzwerken-Technik?
Ich gehe also einfach an Menschen, die ich nicht kenne, und frage sie, ob das gemacht werden kann. Was ist mein Traum? Mein Traum ist, dass Fond-Hotspots sich jeweils verabschieden und dich bewerben, dass in deiner Nachbarschaft und in deiner Nachbarschaft, du mein, ich will, dass das alles durch einen Website passieren. Ich denke, das zählt für viele der offenen WiFi-Netzwerke, die wir jetzt sehen. Und dann will ich, dass das Routen, von dem ich verstehe, so ist, dass es in einer Art, wenn du ein nahe Fonero hast, dann geht die Kommunikation mit diesem Fonero durch das WiFi-Land, das wie ein LAN entstanden ist, und nicht durch das Internet. Aber wenn du kein Fonero bist, wenn du ein Alien bist, ist Fon sehr erfreulich, es kostet 2 Euro für 24 Stunden, um zu jeder Hot-Spot in unserer Netzwerk-Ausgabe zu haben.
Und der Preis ist ein festes Preis? Oder kann ich den Preis für meinen Hot-Spot selbst bestimmen?
Es ist ein festes Preis.
Ist es eine Art Qualität für einen Befehl, den ich in Ordnung von einem Billen anbieten muss?
Die Features sind unglaublich, auch in Qualität der Service. Was die Menschen tun und kontrollieren, ist erstaunlich. Fon wird dich von dem verteidigen.
Die Fon-Software ist eine Verkaufsform für Router. Es gibt nur Linksys Modelle, die die populärsten sind, weil sie das erste System für Linux haben. Die Fon-Software ist aufgrund des OpenWRT-Systems.
Wir denken, das sind zwei fantastische Projekte. Wir haben mit BrainSlayer gearbeitet und ihm die Kosten für die Konsultation bezahlt, um eine verwendete Version von Fon zu entwickeln, die jetzt auf unserer Webseite ist. Ich finde BrainSlayer einen tollen Programmierer. Ich war mit ihm in Dresden gestern. Wir hatten gestern eine gute Begrüßung in Dresden. Das ist ein Teil von dem, was wir haben, das wir Fon Advanced nennen. Das Fon Basic ist ein Development von OpenWRT, das uns für uns ausgestattet wurde. Wir haben jemanden, der zu diesem Podcast hinschaut und mir zu mir schreibt, an martin.fon.com, der Programmierer ist. Wir sind sehr interessiert in mit ihm arbeiten. Wir haben ihn hinkriegen und natürlich Programmierer zu helfen. Aber ich denke, wir haben vier Programmierer in Spanien hinkriegt. Wir hüllen fünf mehr in den nächsten zehn Tagen. Wir lieben diese Projekte und wir denken, dass sie extrem gute Projekte sind. Wir arbeiten auch gestern an Buffalo-Routern. Jetzt arbeiten wir an Buffalo und Linksys. Wir planen, noch mehr Routern zu verwenden. Hier ist eine Einladung zu den Listenern des Programms. Es ist ein anderer. Ich mag das so. Ich würde mich gerne mit Entwicklern einladen, mit uns zusammenzuarbeiten und ihre eigenen Template zu entwickeln.
Deine Webpage spricht von On-Demand, On-Kription-Services.
Ich denke, das betrifft ein Produkt, das er entwickelt hat, das, wenn jemand wirklich Privatschweite auf dem WiFi will, er kann VPN-Tunneling machen, entkrypte Tunneling, und sich einen secure WiFi Signal erhält.
Ok, um die Telefoninfrastruktur in general. tinge WLAN, die eigentlich privat zu sich hat, würde ich sagen.
Und ich sehe WiFi, es gibt eine Epidemie von WiFi. Digital Kameras mit WiFi kommen jetzt, PDFs mit WiFi, Sony PSPs mit WiFi, neun Millionen von denen sind Nintendo DS mit WiFi.
Und glaubst du, du kannst den direkten Unterstützung des Internet-Service-Provideres bekommen?
Was ist der Incentiv? Der Incentiv ist, ihre R&D zu erhöhen und ihren Rang zu reduzieren, was alle ISPs wollen. Sie wollen geliebt werden, wie jeder andere. Es erhöht den Rang, weil wenn die ISPs kaufen, wir mit ihnen Geld teilen und sie nie dachten, dass sie mehr Geld bekommen als etwa 30 Euro pro Monat aus jeder Beziehung. Sie erhöhen ihren Rang, weil man durch sie ein Teil einer globalen Community der Menschen, die WiFi teilen, ein lifetime Membership bekommt, wenn man das tut, und dann will man mit ihnen hinschauen. In Deutschland haben wir 500 Registre Foneros, wie heute, mehr oder weniger 490, wie ich es heute Morgen gesehen habe. Wir haben Christiane Zusalm, die Fonera-Leader in Deutschland ist. Sie kommt aus dem Fernsehen, und das ist sehr überraschend für viele Menschen, die das Internet sehen, aber sie ist wirklich ein fantastischer Entrepreneur. Wir haben auch mit den Leuten von Places gearbeitet. Wir haben auch, interessiert, dass fast jedes Programm, das wir hirbeiten, deutsch ist. Wir arbeiten bereits mit deutschen Programmer, die die meisten Software gemacht haben. Wir haben das. Wir denken, hier in Berlin zu öffnen, weil es für mich die schönste Stadt ist, von dem, was ich in Deutschland gesehen habe, ohne hierher zu sein.
Linux ist in Deutschland immer sehr stark. Ich denke, in Deutschland sind etwa 30% Firefox-Uhrer, die in Deutschland nur Firefox benutzen. WLAN war der einzige Weg zu gehen. Es gibt eine große Verbreitung zwischen Google und Skype-Investment in der Telefonie. Können Sie uns erklären, was Google und Skype in der Telefonie interessiert sind und was dein Interesse in dieser Allianz ist und was andere Allianz in der Telefonie sein können?
Ein ist, dass Larry, Sergey, Megan, Chris und alle Leute an Google das Internet lieben und sie überall das Internet sehen wollen. Und ein anderer Weg ist, mehr zynisch zu sein und zu sagen, dass sie einfach viel Geld machen, die Adresse zu verkaufen. Und sie zeigen mehr Adresse. Und die Zuschauer können glauben, was sie von den beiden Theorien glauben wollen. Ich glaube persönlich, dass die Wahrheit näher zu dem Fakt ist, dass diese Leute das Internet lieben und es überall sehen wollen. Aber sie haben wirklich ihre Leben auf dem Internet verwendet. Die Skype-Leute, Janus und Niklas, sind auf meinem Board und alle auf Skype. Sie haben einen anderen Motiv, das ist, dass sie Skype mobile sehen wollen. Und wir wollen, übrigens, mit jedem WiFi-Netzwerk in Berlin, mit jedem WiFi-Netzwerk in Rom, mit jedem. Wir wollen nur einen globalen, urbanen WiFi-Signal kreieren.
Ich habe die Erinnerung, dass die Google-Skype-Investition auch versucht, die Netzwerke in diesem Sinne zu bleiben.
Aber ich weiß das ganze Gespräch über Netzneutralität. Und ich denke, das ist ziemlich komisch. Die individuelle Wahl einer Person, einer anderen Person. Aber nachdem ich all das gesagt habe, habe ich keine einzige Gespräche mit einer von ihnen über Net Neutrality.
Okay, auch in den Gesprächen gibt es ein paar Projekte, besonders in den USA, aber auch in London, das war vor ein paar Tagen eröffnet. Die Erbindung von freien Wifi-Netzwerken wurde in New Orleans und Chicago und nun auch in London erstmals aufgenommen. Und was ist dein Punkt bei Politikern, die versuchen, das zu verhindern?
Politiker wollen, dass das passiert ist. Telekom-Kompanien wollen, dass das nicht passiert ist. Politiker wollen, dass das passiert ist, weil sie mehr populär sind. Ich kann das sehen. Wir denken, dass wir einen besseren Modell für die Städte haben. Wir denken, dass wir einen besseren Modell haben, weil wir denken, dass wir einen Modell haben, der für den öffentlichen und privaten Partnerschaft nicht die Telekom-Welt verletzt. Sie lassen viele Leute aus ihrer Arbeit und sie stoppen die Investitionen. Man kann sagen, dass es nicht mehr egal ist, weil sie investiert haben, sie haben das Wifi. Aber ich habe jetzt 15 Jahre für Telekom- und ISP-Kompanien gebaut, und ich sehe die Technologie all der Zeit verändern. Ich sehe, dass eine Stadt, die in die Geschäftsarbeit geht, ein Wifi-Kommando ist. Das könnte so ein sowjetisches Problem sein, wo man jetzt guten Dienst gibt, aber dann wird der Dienst schlecht, und dann will jeder es für frei, und jeder steht online, und so weiter. Ich bin nicht in Ordnung davon. Was Fon für die Stadt betrifft, ist, dass wir viele Router an die Stadt donieren, um nur öffentliche Orte zu nutzen, wie Schulen, Libräten, Krankenhäuser, Führer, Polizei, Subway, ich weiß nicht, was du darüber denken kannst. Dann bekommt man Wifi in allen öffentlichen Orten, aber nur in den öffentlichen Orten. Das interviert nicht mit privaten Unternehmen, denn sie sollten natürlich enttäuscht sein, Wifi in allen öffentlichen Orten zu geben. Aber in den öffentlichen Orten propozieren wir das Fond-Modell, in dem alle ihre Wifi-Router von Windows kaufen, die ISP bezahlen, damit die ISP nicht abwischen. Unser Fond-Modell ist also frei für die, die ein Donor sind, und auch für die, die kein Donor sind. Es verletzt die Telekom-Spieler nicht. Und es kostet die Stadt keine Geld.
Okay, danke dir sehr für die Explanation.
Wenn sie wollen wissen, wie Fon gebaut wurde, dann gehen sie auf meinen Blog, martinvarsavsky.net, denn mein Blog ist das Blog eines Unternehmers, das eine Firma baut. Also jemand, der sich interessiert oder trägt, eine Firma zu bauen, oder möchte unsere Geschichte wissen, kann auf meinen Blog gehen. Wenn jemand ein Programmer ist oder eine Frage hat, dann kann er auch an martin.fon.com schreiben.
Vielen Dank für die Information. Das war mein Interview mit Martin Varsavsky. Ein interessantes Projekt, wie ich finde, dass man sich mal ein bisschen näher anschauen sollte, mal gucken was draus wird. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall sehr vielversprechend. Insbesondere, weil es eine gute Alternative darstellt zu dem aktuellen Hotspot FUBA, den ihr ja selber überall sehen könnt. Diese ganzen AOL und Telekom Hotspots, die versuchen sich da gegenseitig bei den Restaurants auszuboten und am Ende führt es einfach nur dazu, dass in diesen Restaurants und Cafés schlicht und ergreifend kein Internet genutzt wird. Ich denke, die einzigen Orte, wo die Leute wirklich das auch benutzen, ist halt, wo sie wirklich jetzt keine andere Wahl haben. Also in Hotels, im Zimmer, Flughäfen und so was. Aber das kann ja wohl nicht die Antwort sein. Insofern muss man schauen. Interessant fand ich den Hinweis, dass in anderen Ländern eben ISPs schon auch kooperieren mit FON. Das könnte wirklich dazu führen, dass sich hier alles ein bisschen öffnet. Aber wir wollen auch nicht zu viel Optimismus verbreiten hier. Vielleicht ist das ja auch alles bekloppt. Ich möchte da auch gerne eure Meinungen zu hören. Und wenn ihr auch technische Fragen habt, dann wie immer, nutzt die Feedback-Möglichkeiten von Chaosradio. Entweder schickt ihr eine E-Mail an chaosradio.accc.de oder ihr ruft einfach schnell mal an auf unserer tollen Rufnummer unter 018 01 99 33 22 99 55. Und das war Chaosradio, die Ausgabe 9 10. Und ich hoffe, es geht ja auch wieder weiter. Die Themen reißen nicht ab. Und wenn ihr auch weiterhin noch Vorschläge habt für Themen, dann bitte auch das im Feedback erwähnen. Ja, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag und bis bald.